he is the epitome of what a man should
be to me he is perfect he is amazing he
is a leader he is basically the beyonce
for boys
with animation yeah i know that you
don't because i've done animation as
well so you don't get to actually see
the co-stars a lot of times
but how cool is it to work with dwayne
johnson like you all saw each other a
bit obviously so how cool was that yeah
it was wonderful i actually met him
after the recording was all finished we
met at a press junket
and i was finally able to like put the
voice
to the face and he's massive
and plays this amazing maui who's a
bigger than life character
so well he's kind he gives great hugs
he smells good my mom has a joke that
when
she first met him she went rock climbing
so there's also that
all around oh my god i love you
it was an experience great joke
[Music]
you have you have not one but three
pictures of the rocks
yes what does this mean what is your
point
[Laughter]
i mean i love the rock too it's just on
your vision board that's cool
yeah i love the rock you want anything
he is the epitome of what a man should
be
to me he is perfect he is amazing he is
a leader he is basically the beyonce for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
boys
so is he on your vision board because
you want to work with him
i want to work with him i want to be
like him i want him to carry me while i
eat ice cream
obviously i know your first thought when
the accident happened was oh my gosh i'm
not going to get to see kelly clarkson
monday
it's the first time i know the first
time i thought but it's okay we're here
okay good good i knew you would care um
no but your pal doing johnson he did us
a favor though solid because
y'all are really close friends and he
actually came and he represented you
on our show he did me a big favor man uh
and you know what it was without me even
asking he said kev i know you had some
stuff to do you had stuff on your plate
uh this is when you get to see how close
your brother actually is i'm gonna stand
in and i'm gonna make sure that i can do
what i can
while you're in your time of need he's
uh he's a he's a he's a good guy
like people don't understand the
friendship is actually 100
real and authentic so it looks real for
him to do the things that he did for me
it was uh
it was it was it was touching it was it
was a heartwarming moment
but uh i didn't tell him you know at the
time i was like you better do it
because you don't have a chance i said
you don't have a choice that your
friends do
i would do it for you no i wouldn't i
wouldn't do it forever
no i wouldn't we actually have tape of
him you know talking about you
you hadn't actually planned on being
here your baby brother kevin hart
he was supposed to be here but he was in
a car weeks ago so everything's good
with him now though right
everything is good i spoke with kevin
and you know what these things happen in
life and
thankfully he uh was strapped in nicely
to his car seat so i think that
everything
[Laughter]
knew y'all were real friends yeah
well today we have a bunch of working
women it's 95 we're celebrating that so
i want to know
well i want to know like if you had to
pick one person
i'm sure there's many but if you pick
one person the most influential woman
in your life what would you say that is
there's this is a two-parter so number
one would be my mom
who's been such a good
she's been the quintessential rock of
the family gone through tough times
yeah she she is yeah i'm the pebble
she's real luck uh
but so i would say her but and then
certainly after being with lauren my
wife now for over 10 years and just
when i watch her over the years and
certainly with our babies
and her doing everything that she
possibly can to make sure that it's as
normal as it could possibly be
our babies have good perspective and
handling the household
handling me which can be a big pain in
the butt our life
the complexities that that brings and i
also i was talking to her last night so
we moved
in the past three years since our babies
have been born um
over 25 times for my work in three years
now when i say we've moved she's moved
like the babies in the house and the
dogs and the things like that
and i look at her i'm like you are my
superwoman so it would have to be oh my
gosh
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever